okay so okay let's check this out okay
so this one time in college man I was
straight kicking game to this beautiful
chick Diana man and that's a house party
and so anyway I go to the kitchen to
grab us a couple of beers man I kid you
not I slipped on a banana peel you good
yeah man uh what are you doing Oh me it
was a funny story I was like can let it
out man just just laugh I am yeah so
anyway you know I get up right now go to
grab a beer and I forget they always
hooking up when they fell right
I kid you not this beer exploded in my
crotch I look like I peed myself
[Laughter]
don't hit my couch come on come on yeah
I'm just laughing with y'all well we
were laughing you weren't you you know
make any noise you just open your mouth
and you're jiggling you look like a worm
on crack
you know I guess everybody just has
their own unique laugh okay let me you
will not laughing you were not a mini
sound about your mouth man hey oh good
tell you story thank you Oh anyway I
went back to the kitchen to get two
fresh beers and she said I hate beer but
where did my banana go and so then we
called it Chiquita Diana
hey don't do this don't touch my hey
come on come on okay you just laugh
sometimes all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
see that's why I didn't want to laugh
[Music]
have a good life
[Music]
you